all right bud one more flight there has
just been a friggin avalanche of
trailers lately and it's been really
annoying because I would like to have
ignored what there were a lot that I did
into her I would like to have ignored
more of them but a lot of these I want
to talk about so as a result of this yet
two videos yesterday you're getting two
videos today I don't like doing more
than one video in the day I feel like
I'm spamming people's feeds when I do
that but this is what I got to do
otherwise it throws my entire month
schedule completely out of whack ah
serves me right for trying to plan ahead
so how to train your dragon' 3 first
trailer I am really nervously excited
about this film because I really liked
the first how to drain your dragon and I
loved the second how to train your
dragon these movies in the way that they
have built on each other and the themes
and the characters and the music and the
visuals and like this is one of the only
movie series that I I go out of my way
to see in 3d because if you have not
seen the flying sequences in 3d it's
seriously like this and avatar were the
only things that I could think of like
that is like 3d is how I want to see
this I still see movies in 3ds but
that's like only if a 3d screening is
the only thing that I can get to in
terms of the timing my schedule and
whatever else but how to train your
dragon this is a series I love to see in
3d because it's just magic watching
these flying sequences and I love these
movies to death and I was nervous
because I do love these and I have a lot
of faith in the people behind them
because they it's maintaining the same
team and they've made some really bold
and very smart decisions in the telling
of these stories and the way things have
unfolded but at the same time you know
there are plenty of series where you get
one or even two great entries and then
there isn't enough gas left in the tank
to cap it off right you know spider-man
3
Godfather 3 Dark Knight Rises you know
the third entries even when it is
actually intended to close out a series
can be really rough but then again every
now and then it works you get a Toy
Story 3 so what do I think about this
trailer there's a lot to like here and
seeing wonderful emphasis put on the
interaction of these characters and then
bouncing off each other and so much
emphasis on the bond between hiccup and
toothless because that really is the
heart of this and has been since the
beginning and there is a sense of
melancholy and finality to this trailer
and I expect to will be in the movie
that I hope will make me sad in a
satisfying way because you know I would
be very sad will be very sad to see this
series end at the same time I if it's
going to end I wanted to end properly
and ending the series properly probably
means making me cry and I'm game for
that and that they don't seem to be
hiding where they're going with this cuz
things have been said it was early
enough in the development that I didn't
know if it was gonna hold true all the
way through because I think animation
possibly more than any other type of
filmmaking
can really transform from when you start
to when you finish but there was stuff
said very early on that this film was
gonna be about why dragons aren't around
anymore and even if the answer isn't
they all died and went extinct it's
that's still going to be sad however
that ends up being so I and they're
there they seem to be being really a
with this being the tone of it this
being the mood of it
and I I appreciate that boldness because
the the franchise has been pretty bold
with its with its handling of serious
moments serious questions so all of that
makes me really happy stuff that is more
just kind of its kind of cutes things
like toothless and the light fury I
guess we're calling it um that's the
kind of thing I'm a little skeptical of
but then sort of watching them together
I'm like okay yeah that's cute
like I I would love some more context on
that might make a break how much I like
it but like okay yeah that's cute
and and and I can roll with that and I'm
good with that
if I'm nervous about anything it's
possible recycling of stuff that we saw
last time and saying that I'm mainly
thinking about what I can see of the
villain and also this idea of hiccup
having stumbled across some sort of
dragon land whatever it might be because
that's not particularly dissimilar to
what happened in How to Train Your
Dragon to where he basically found his
mother's Dragon Sanctuary and you know
it was just sort of this this little
isolated pocket and it looks like
whatever they stumble across and this
one is much bigger than that but it's in
principle kind of the same thing so that
makes me nervous and the villain we
don't know you know we don't really know
much about him we don't see a lot of him
but he talks about hunting dragons and
we also see him having at least one at
his command as well and so maybe he
doesn't have an army of dragons the the
way that the villain and the second one
did but it does appear to be he does
appear to have at least one so it's
ringing similar notes to the villain
from the second one and that makes me
nervous as well because I I would I
would be really
sad if the film ended up hinging its its
concluding plot on a redundant
repetitive villain so those are the two
things that are nervous about but only
slightly nervous because again at this
point I have a pretty good amount of
confidence in this team to deliver
something really great and I and I I'm
not I'm not expecting to be let down but
if you've been around at all then then
you know me and I if I see something
that is a potential issue even in a
trailer and a franchise that I otherwise
really really like I'm still gonna bring
it up because I refuse to put blinders
on like I and and these things that I
pointed out are not automatic pitfalls
they're just things I'm looking at going
I hope that is not the bad version of
what I could see it being I just hope
it's not that because that's what it is
it's me hoping that these are not issues
but recognizing that they could
potentially be I'm tangent thing a
little bit now but I feel like I get
accused of being a buzzkill and I can be
but a little more than is warranted
because I just I like to be realistic
about the challenges that any given film
project can face and as I gave more
information about it what those
challenges could be in my sense of them
is gonna change it's either gonna firm
up and go yeah that's gonna be the
problem or it'll be like okay seems okay
just watch out for that but we'll see
and I'm really hopeful for this because
I I enjoyed the first one greatly the
the second one the year that it came out
it was my favorite movie that year I
I've got a lot of hope sort of poured
into this because I would love a really
strong completed trilogy out of this
story because I've enjoyed the heck out
of it so how to train your dragon 3
first trailer or what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do support me
on patreon like subscribe follow me on
Twitter podcast buy a t-shirt links for
all this
and things that I didn't even remember
to mention are down in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]